la prius
[Musique]
mathieu bat mathieu c'est moi tu sais
il ya des soirs comme ça où tout
s'écroule autour de nous
sans trop savoir pourquoi toujours
regarder devant soi
n'ont jamais baissé les bras je sais
je suis pas le remède à dessous
mais faussement c'est parfois mathieu
mathieu dépêche toi on vit
j'en ai marre que nous fout
mais on a le temps de rien
que c'est déjà la fin mais c'est pas
marqué dans les livres
que plus important à vivre c'est de
vivre au jour le jour
peut-on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus important un livre c'est le niveau
je rejoue le temps
[Musique]
c'est de l'amour
pascal
pascal jusqu'au pascal pascal mon chéri
pascal est ce que est ce que ça vous
fait vraiment du mal parce que ça vous
fait vraiment quoi s'en vient et c'est
bon pour la saône et je vais donc pour
la santé non mais vous faire d'avoir
faire si tu veux faire moi c'est vrai
moitié moitié moitié n'ont rien lâché
il attendait sa carrière là bas
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pascal et émouvant même quand ils
sentent une petite annonce sur le
refrain de millésimes ça c'est à ces
pages dentiste mais arrêt arrêté pascal
on est fou de cette journée a battu
cycle et à à la loge juste on sait vous
êtes un très bon musicien on s'est dit
on va lui mettre un clavier toi c'est
quoi pascal c'est sans être l'interprète
par exemple si vous sentez une plaie non
sur leur faim de millésima vendresse
tuning contrôle t pain toqué attention
sur une petite annonce sur l'illusion
vous allez voir mais je dois vous faire
pleurer chez vous pascal obispo ces
partis parce qu elle décède en sait un
peu de cela c'est un peu son invité
invité du sari n'aura avant elle reste
unie
contrôler avec sièges en cuir tout juste
installé
kif l'opa à mutations qui sur la les
portes il ya des éclats
et c'est une fête
un essai boel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]